[Musique]
bonsoir à tous mercredi 24 avril
bienvenue dans le 7-8 journal de tv 78
c'est le tour d'horizon de l'actualité
locale tout de suite les titres de cette
édition
quarante deux mille cinq cents panneaux
solaires pour fournir l'électricité aux
habitants de triel-sur-seine ce projet
est en train de se concrétiser d'ici
2021 une ferme photovoltaïque pourrait
voir le jour sur le site d'une ancienne
décharge
une enquête publique est en cours en
attendant la validation du dossier
après trois ans de réflexion l'identité
du lieu a été défini à magny les hameaux
la plaine de chemin cours sera un espace
dédié aux loisirs de nouveaux
équipements vont venir s'ajouter au
gymnase terrain de football et parcours
santé déjà existants et les travaux
devraient démarrer cet été
et puis venez repousser vos limites
physiques et mentales ce week-end un
bootcamp avec les pompiers de paris se
tient samedi prochain en forêt de saint
germain en laye est le principe franchir
un parcours du combattant inspiré des
sessions d'entraînement militaire
présentation avec notre invité est en
plateau tout à l'heure également le
dirigeant fondateur de pops icub cette
entreprise saint-quentinoise vient
d'ouvrir une nouvelle filiale à moscou
en russie
on débute ce journal avec ces images
impressionnantes celle d'un incendie qui
s'est déclaré hier à 17 heures rue du
parc de clagny à versailles un garage
automobile a été détruit par les flammes
un seul blessé léger a déploré un
ouvrier qui a été incommodé par les
dégagements de fumée 86 pompiers 24
véhicules 12 10 et 20 policiers en
étaient notamment mobilisés pour
maîtriser le feu pour le moment la cause
de cet incendie restent méconnus une
soudure pourrait en être à l'origine
l enquête a été confiée au commissariat
de versailles et dernière ligne droite
pour le projet de ferme photovoltaïque à
triel sur seine une enquête publique est
en cours si ce projet est validé par les
autorités les habitants pourront
bénéficier de cette électricité verte
est les détails sur ce sujet avec
aurélie rond et patrick jacques de
dixmude d'ici 2021
cette ancienne décharge devenu une
friche naturel pourrait accueillir une
ferme photovoltaïque de 20 hectares
situé en bordure de la départementale
190 42500 panneaux solaires permettront
de fournir de l'ailé
réciter à l'ensemble des habitants de
triel sur seine on a été il ya des
années des années une des premières
communes à être une commune
verte on a toujours continué dans cet
esprit a travaillé à faire du tri
sélectif est donc une panneau solaire
l'énergie renouvelable c'est aussi notre
notre souci il y a dix ans le projet
avait été abandonné en raison de
l'instabilité du sol
une enquête publique a été lancée au
début du mois d'avril
objectif permettre aux habitants d'en
savoir plus sur cette ferme
photovoltaïque c'est bien c'est pour
l'écologie c'est pour le climat donc
c'est bien que des avantages on va
remplacer des déchets parmi quelque
chose de favorable à la à la nature dans
le contexte actuel c'est pas quand même
pas une mauvaise idée plutôt qu'une
décharge
enfin sur une décharge on pourra rien
faire donc donc change tout c'est une
bonne solution aujourd'hui une
alternative écologique intéressante pour
la société urbasolar a été choisi pour
aménager ce parc solaire estimé à 18
mégawatts
en plus d'être une zone inconstructible
le site possède également un autre
intérêt on a un poste de transformation
et les f à proximité donc le
raccordement
il faut pas tirer du capa entre 3 km ça
c'était un avantage pour nous dans les
prochaines semaines le dossier sera
entre les mains de la creuse la
commission de régulation de l'énergie
c'est cet organisme indépendant qui est
chargé de valider ou non le projet
verdict aux alentours du mois de
septembre et un projet similaire
pourrait voir le jour à gargenville sur
le site de total le groupe réfléchit à
implanter une ferme photovoltaïque qui
pourrait fonctionner pour la
consommation électrique de 14000
personnes l'énergie seraient revendus
ensuite à edf une enquête publique se
déroule jusqu'au 27 mai début des
travaux espéré deuxième trimestre 2020
découverte macabre ce mardi un corps
enroulé dans du grillage a été repêché
dans la seine au niveau de guern c'est
un plaisancier qui a donné l'alerté hier
en début d'après midi le cadavre très
abîmé potentiellement par un long séjour
dans l'eau n'a pu être identifié pour le
moment le sexe de l'individu
elle n'est pas encore déterminé une
autopsie doit être pratiquée ce jeudi à
la piste criminelle est privilégiée
les gendarmes de la section de
recherches de versailles et de la
brigade de recherches de mantes la jolie
vont mener les investigations et du golf
du fitness et un parcours d'athlétisme
voilà à quoi ressemblera la future
plaine de chemin cours des équipements
sportifs existe déjà mais la mairie de
magny les hameaux veut accueillir plus
de monde
le reportage de calypso vanier ici on va
avoir un espace d'initiation au golf la
plaine de chemin cour transformée en
lieu de loisirs après trois ans de
réflexion avec ses concitoyens le maire
de magny les hameaux
bertrand au lion a défini ce projet on
va voir aussi un espace d'athlétisme
pour tout ce qui est donc pistes pour
tout ce qui est chaud est lancé qui
situera donc juste derrière le terrain
de football et en lien aussi avec avec
l'espace de golf un gymnase un terrain
de football et un parcours santé
existent déjà sur cette plaine bucolique
mais la mairie souhaite accueillir plus
de monde
elle va créer 60 places de stationnement
et les manies quoi pourront profiter de
tables de pique nique et de jeux pour
enfants
notre objectif est d'en faire un lieu de
loisirs un lieu de sport et puis un lieu
finalement très familiale de détente de
rencontre de partage plus de 2,6
millions d'euros c'est le coût de ce
projet d'aménagement il est financé
notamment par l'agglomération de saint
quentin en yvelines
la région et le département après un
appel d'offres lancé en mars
les travaux devraient commencer cet été
ouverture prévue dès cet automne un mot
de politique avec du changement au sein
du conseil municipal de trappes un élu
de la majorité
quitte le groupe luke de vern déjà des
rangs de la république en marche devient
indépendant raison avancée de profonds
désaccords avec l'équipe majoritaire
ils avaient été élus en 2014 sur la
liste du maire divers gauche guy
malandain tout comme gerald de moniot
ancien maire adjoint de trappes qui
avait quitté la majorité en 2016 pour
devenir indépendant lui a décidé de
rejoindre le groupe d'opposition trappe
citoyens mené par othman nzru pour lui
la ville a besoin de renouveau d'où son
choix de se rallier à l'élu les
républicains à un an
des municipales économie avec mon
premier invité fabrice beauchesne
bonsoir vous êtes le dirigeant fondateur
de pop si cuba lors cette pme est basée
à montigny le bretonneux et spécialisée
dans la recherche clinique et une
nouveauté pour votre entreprise incite
désormais à moscou une filiale en russie
vous avez inauguré ses locaux tout
récemment ce que vous êtes revenu hier
de ce voyage en russie est ce qu'on peut
dire que c'est un nouveau pas
considérable pour votre entreprise
ah oui bien sûr toute création de
filiales à porte je tairai son look de
pub attitude surtout d'espérance donc là
on démarre avec une nouvelle équipe sur
moscou donc on est impatient et on va
présenter dans un instant cette équipe
alors pop si cuba était créée en 2004
d'abord installée dans la pépinière
promo paul de montigny le bretonneux et
vous avez désormais des locaux dans le
quartier du pas du lac toujours à
montigny le bretonneux une
spécialisation dans la recherche
clinique c'est ça quelles sont vos
activités
la recherche clinique c'est on teste les
nouveaux médicaments ou les dispositifs
médicaux d'accord pour l'industrie
pharmaceutique
donc principalement met en place des
protocoles scientifiques avec des
médecins qui sont eux basés à l'hôpital
et en fait nous on va gérer toute
l'infrastructure et toute la logistique
donc aider les médecins recrutés les
patients faire les tests récolter les
données faire les analyses statistiques
faire des bons rapports qu'ils ont après
donner aux agences du médicament pour
approuver ou pas les médicaments
mais depuis 2004 quel a été le parcours
de l'entreprise est ce que son son
développement a été rapide rapide je
sais pas maintenant on arrive à
quarantaine de salariés mais que en 14
ans s'est passé c'est très rapide mais
effectivement on est assez satisfait
j'ai démarré tout seul donc certaine
satisfaction maintenant d'avoir une
vraie entreprise une vraie pme avec
plusieurs bureaux dans le monde donc ça
c'est assez intéressant
vous êtes justement présent dans le
monde en chine vous avez un bureau
commercial est également une filiale aux
états unis
est ce que cette présence à
l'international est ce que ça se ressent
sur votre croissance quelque chose que
vous avez remarqué
oui oui parce que la recherche clinique
maintenant et globalisé c'était en fait
l'industrie pharmaceutique essayent de
lancer des médicaments partout dans le
monde au même moment
donc l'idée effectivement c'est pour eux
d'avoir des sociétés comme les nôtres
les plus internationales possible alors
nous on a la capacité spécifique cité
d'être à taille humaine ce qui fait
qu'on touche des plus petits
laboratoires que les très grands
mondiaux l'effectivité internationale
elle et elle est importante aujourd'hui
pour exister un secteur importante
quasiment tous les projets congères sont
au minimum europe etats unis et là
effectivement l'idée c'est d'aller un
peu plus à l'est
voir sur la route de la soie puisque
actuellement donc leur vient de créer la
russie avec un potentiel énorme qu'il
lui en soit l'art la russie souhaite
développer son industrie pharmaceutique
locale
donc effectivement il ya des obligations
locales donc potentiellement des projets
et en chine c'est plutôt l'inversé ça il
ya beaucoup de laboratoires
pharmaceutiques chinois qui souhaitent
venir vendre leurs produits en europe
ok des besoins différents selon les
secteurs du monde justement la russie
pourquoi choisir où commencer à en
parler
pourquoi choisir de s'implanter en
russie
on va dire que l'europe est déjà bien
implanté de société comme la nôtre la
russie depuis quelques années se
développe beaucoup il ya une pharmacopée
russe qui se renforce donc qui oblige en
fait les laboratoires trois outils qu'à
aller chercher des patients russie ou à
développer des études spécifiquement en
russie
et puis c'était aussi l'occasion de
comme toujours c'est une relation
humaine donc effectivement on a
rencontré une équipe sur place et ça ça
a collé cette implantation at elle été
rendue possible comment finalement on
installe une filiale à l'étranger
quelles sont les démarches à faire pour
pour une pme alors pour dans notre cas
là pour moscou en fait ce sont donc des
une équipe russe qui était qui travaille
dans un laboratoire qui est venu nous
voir en disant on cherche à s'adosser à
une entreprise pour développer une
activité et donc du coup bénéficier des
outils que nous on avait déjà inventé
mis en place après la partie on va dire
juridique est un peu compliqué surtout
quand on parle pas la langue du pays et
qu'on n'écrit pas l'alphabet donc on
s'est fait accompagner par une société
dont le dirigeant est français qui est
basé en russie et qui aide les
entreprises à s'implanter en russie et
donc qui organise tout le parcours un
peu du combattant donc moi mon rôle ça a
été de faire un post signé des documents
donc c'est des termes qu'on apprend ce
qu'il faut entreprendre des documents
les faire valider par la mairie ou le
tribunal de commerce et après le
tribunal de versailles l'aggraver faire
tamponner et après on part avec tout ça
il en reste sur des présences pour le
coût local fut locales pour pour réussir
en russie combien de personnes seront
présentes sur place et qu'est ce
qu'elles vont y faire concrètement dans
cette dans cette filiale alors pour
l'instant on a trois personnes en russie
une gestionnaire une personne qui va
faire toute la partie commerciale et une
chef de projet a commencé à gérer les
premiers projets donc voilà pour pour
commencer en russie ce qui a déjà des
contrats des clients qui ont été trouvés
sur place signée sur place ce que c'est
déjà le cas où là le travail maintenant
s'enclenche pour le co c'est en cours
ouais on a beaucoup de pistes puisque on
a une dizaine de projets en discussion
donc on espère bien qu'il y en a
quelques-uns qui un petit stress
harcèlement et les objectifs du coup sûr
sur place avec cette nouvelle
implantation quels objectifs vous fixez
ben c'est qu'on trouve les premiers
projets enfin on fait à chaque fois les
étapes par étapes
première étape c'est de trouver des
premiers projets et après effectivement
de constituer une équipe de plus en plus
grande
voilà où on est on est maintenant 25 à
montigny l'objectif c'est d'ici 3 4 ans
ça soit par ayant aussi et poursuivre
pourquoi pas ce sera le mot de la fin
sur la croissance de 2018 qui a été
assez fort pour votre pme qui est une
croissance de 60% en 2018 oui bah on à
l'internationalisation on a on a deux
spécificités c'est qu'on est taille
humaine on à la partie internationale et
on a aussi une grosse partie digital et
ça prend tout son sens si en 2004 on
était un peu précurseur maintenant avec
tous les objets connectés autres la
recherche clinique utilisent de plus en
plus tu skies et objets connectés pour
éclairer qui font que dire des données
donc les perspectives sont bonnes la les
percées des perspectives sont très
bonnes
merci fabrice beauchesne d'être passé à
sur ce plateau dirigeant fondateur de
pop six cuvées je le rappelle elle vient
de s'implanter du coup en russie à
moscou avec cette nouvelle filiale en
france on revient en france il faut dix
mille dons de sang par jour il permettra
de soigner plus d'un million de malades
chaque année l'établissement français du
sang organise régulièrement des
collectes est l'un d'entre eux l'une
d'entre elles plutôt se tenait ce
week-end à versailles avec une
particularité une collation gastronomie
qui étaient offertes au public mélanie
poker un buffet sucré salé pour dire
merci aux donneurs des victuailles
préparé par le traiteur versailles et
gaulupeau une idée de la table ronde
française de versailles un club composé
d'hommes pour la première édition
on a contacté le fs on leur a proposé
notre projet et ils ont tout de suite
accroché
en plus ils ont besoin de ce type
d'événement pour avoir constamment des
poches de sang à disposition et les
week-ends comme aujourd'hui week-end de
pâques sont des week-ends assez creux
pour eux un don dure environ une heure
dès 10 heures ce samedi les yvelinois
répondait présent j'ai de commencer à
donner dans le cadre de l'art mais
j'étais militaire avant et donc bon
c'est aussi une facilité logistique que
j'ai de donner tous les mois je pense
que tout le monde est susceptible d'en
avoir besoin un jour en ce moment il ya
une campagne qui nous dit que donner son
sang c'est sauver 3 vies
donc je trouve ça comment incitateur
pour cette deuxième édition de don du
sang gastronomes une quarantaine de
donneurs se sont donné rendez vous
l'établissement français possède
actuellement 14 sites fixes en ile de
france et organise près de 3000 collecte
moby parents en ces vacances de
printemps pourquoi pas à tester vos
limites physiques et surtout mentale le
tout dans une ambiance conviviale et
militaire ce samedi un bootcamp est
proposée par les pour avec les pompiers
de paris ça se passe de 9h30 à 11h30 en
forêt de saint germain en laye pour en
parler une nouvelle invitée avec moi en
plateau géraldine nizar bonsoir pensant
êtes coach sportive également co
organisatrice de ce bout de campagne est
clé les pompiers de paris déjà que quel
est le principe d'un bout de kanpe en
bootcamp c'est une activité en extérieur
qui fait sur une activité sur surtout
sur la nature donc quand on utilise ce
qu'ont à l'extérieur donc là ça va se
passer effectivement en forêt de saint
germain en laye pour par rapport à la
proximité notamment des adhérents
qui vont y participer puisqu'il parie
prête pas dans une vienne du studio
fitness-club d'orgeval et donc fallait
le trouver une proximité des gens dans
le 78 la forêt de saint germain en laye
est assez grande pour pouvoir faire pas
mal d'activités mais un but comme ça
fait aussi forcément écho aux
entraînements militaires
exactement donc après il ya différentes
thématiques mais effectivement on a
choisi deux bouts de compte plutôt
commando avec les pompiers de paris donc
en exclusivité parce qu'effectivement
c'est rare de pouvoir les avoir donc ils
me font l'honneur de venir de chaises de
paris jusque chez nous pour pouvoir nous
proposer des activités en exclusivité
c'est une vraie chance ou et d'avoir ces
pompiers paris qu'on le rappelle ils
sont militaires les pompiers de paris
dont pour pour animer ce goût de crampes
c'est une activité militaire donc là on
va vraiment avoir des différents
ateliers comme le montrent et de cordes
le tirage de pneus après je peux pas
tout vous dire parce qu'il ya certaines
surprises
mais voilà faut s'attendre à tout et le
but c'est de dépasser ses limites dans
une ambiance effectivement militaire
mais surtout convivial et fan quand même
mais pourquoi proposer ce rendez vous
c'est justement d'avoir un moment festif
un moment convivial peut-être en outre
nos pratiques en pratique plutôt en
intérieur donc là c'est de les sortir de
leur confort de l'intérieur de la salle
pour se rencontrer dans une autre
ambiance pouvoir faire venir peut-être
leurs enfants leurs maris leurs femmes
en fonction effectivement des
participants donc tout le monde peut y
participer encore dernièrement une maman
qui me dit ma mamma filiale à 14h30 est
ce qu elle peut participer ben oui si
c'est pour a voilà le côté fun challenge
montrer qu'on peut aussi bien faire que
les adultes
oui c'est possible que ça veut dire
qu'on soit un sportif chevronné un
sportif du dimanche qu'on veuille
simplement dépasser nos limites ça
s'adresse vraiment à tout le moins
accessible à tout le monde on a des
personnes alors je vais peut-être vous
faire sourire après on a des personnes
qui sont plutôt à la retraite par
exemple est effectivement qui sont dire
mais pourquoi pas et puis moi je vais
montrer aussi aux jeunes que je peux le
faire
voilà il n'y a pas que les jeunes y a
pas parce qu'on fait que du crossfit
qu'on peut y arriver n'importe qui il
suffit d'avoir le mental et les pompiers
sont là pour ça que je pense qu'ils vont
nous faire rigoler aussi peut-être un
peu moins sûrs certains
certains parcours mais voilà c'est le
but c'est de se retrouver dans une bonne
ambiance et d'oser repousser ses limites
et ce genre de concepts comme le bund
campe aussi ces événements je pense aux
hommes et des houles invitent les
participants justement repousser ses
limites ça c'est des concepts qu'on va
de plus en plus il
la cote ces concepts on nous on nous l'a
réclamé l'année dernière donc on a créé
une sim effectivement ils ont appelé ces
mêmes les adhérents qui nous ont demandé
de créer une team sfc pour le mode des
de l'année dernière vu qu'il se passait
dans le 78 est quand même assez simple
ils nous ont demandé de le refaire cette
année donc ils montrent l'implication
des côtes
l'implication des gens de l'accueil les
autres participants chacun s'entraînent
les uns les autres
les plus jeunes et plus âgées donc c'est
assez motivés en fait pour tout le monde
et même les gens de l'extérieur qui font
pas partie du club par exemple ou envie
d'y participer parce que c'est quelque
chose hors normes entre guillemets est
sympa on n'a pas besoin effectivement
d'avoir des gros bras de fer du sport
tous les jours chacun que y arriver avec
ses capacités donc c'est ce qui est
sympa et c'est vrai que le bootcamp est
arrivé un peu pour l'entraînement au
modèle puisque le mode d avoir avoir
lieu si je me trompe pas au mois de juin
donc le but c est de pouvoir s'entraîner
à s'entraîner en vue du modèle c'est ça
et il ya aussi un côté important on l'a
entendu dans vos réponses et l'esprit
d'équipé
finalement c'est de ne pas y arriver
seul à franchir ses limites ça se fait
en équipe c'est important c'est le plus
important c'est qu'on n'est pas là sur
un sport individuel
on est vraiment là sur la cohésion
d'équipé ce qu'on veut montrer
aujourd'hui qu'on peut y arriver tous
ensemble qu'on soit vieux qu'on soit
jeune qu'on soit handicapé ou partie
accessible à tous tout le monde peut y
arriver je vous parlais tout à l'heure
du lieu la particularité du lieu de la
forêt de saint-germain-en-laye ce que
c'est un théâtre idéal pour faire ce
genre d'activité assez accessible à tous
c'est vrai qu'à côté de la piscine de
saint germain on a un grand cap parking
parce que ce qu'il faut sur ce type
d'activité c'est la rendre accessible
mais la rendre accessible dès le moment
où on y arrive donc un grand parking on
peut s'y garer facilement
on peut venir avec ses enfants le voient
là y'en a un qui peut garder les enfants
l'autre prat participe au bout de compte
par exemple
et puis la forêt de saint germain la cua
dans le 78 je pense qu'elle est assez
connue pour pour pouvoir y faire beau
parcours que ce soit au vélo à pied
voilà les enfants les grands on peut
tout y faire donc les plans pire
également et faire du sport et les
pompiers ont trouvé leur but
un dieu alors sans tout dévoiler ce que
vous voulez vous l'avez dit il y aura
des surprises quel est le programme
grosso modo de cette matinée donc on
commence à 9h30 accueil à peu près à
9h30
il y aura forcément des retardataires
mais ça dure effectivement jusqu'à 11h30
deux équipes qui vont un peu s'affronter
quand même si c'est dans une esprit d
équipe et à la fin c'est de se retrouver
autour d'un pique nique pour que ce soit
effectivement l'ambiance conviviale avec
les pompiers faire le débrief voir
comment ça s'est passé pourquoi pas en
organiser un après avoir avec leur plein
mais aussi parce que ce n'est pas
forcément évident les avoir tout le
temps mais voilà c'est le pen y apprend
on recommande surtout au niveau de la
tenue mais plutôt d'une tenue par don
près du corps d'accord on peut
recommander éventuellement des mitaines
mais plutôt des mitaines d'escaladé sa
part rien mais pour avoir testé le mode
de l'année dernière quand vous montez à
la corde que l'accord d'aller mouiller
et des mitaines classique c'est pas
forcément pratique si vous voulez pas
voir dans pool
voilà où on préconise est plutôt une
tenue près du corps prévoyait plutôt
aussi les sacs plastiques pour le après
c'est à dire que si vous voulez rentrer
dans votre voiture plutôt propre vous
voyez le maillot de bain en dessous la
tenue on remet tout dans le sac et on
sera bits pour voir partir donc une
tenue adaptée on l'a compris ce qu'on
peut encore s'inscrire est ce qu'il
reste des places où il reste quelques
places après c'est quand même en place
limité parce que il ya deux pompiers qui
viennent sinon ils doivent s'organiser
vraiment au dernier moment mais on
accepte on accepte et on s'organisera en
est besoin c'est sûrement affiché
pendant l'entretien et va s'afficher à
nouveau pour pour s'inscrire
le type d'obstacle juste pour avoir une
idée c'est que les participants auront à
franchir le type d'obstacle il va y
avoir un parcours de singe par exemple
ce qu'on appelle le pont de singe pardon
il y aura le monde et de cordes
il va y avoir ce que je vous disais les
pneus et peut-être plus ou moins gros
alors pour ceux qui connaissent je pense
qu'ils savent à quoi s'attendre
pourquoi re parcours dans la boue ramper
voilà des choses se porte et pourquoi
pas ceux portés par exemple mais voilà
le même - je connais pas tout tous les
autres noms là puisqu'il était surpris
jouissent aussi le cas pour participer à
cette activité
quand on est adhérent ses 15 euros et
les non adhérents c'est ferrero donc
assez accessible on voulait vraiment
rendre cette activité accessible pour
montrer que le sport est accessible à
tous c'est ce qui est important
la boue de caen avec les pompiers de
paris c'est ce samedi de 9h30 à 11h30 en
forêt de saint germain en laye toutes
les informations sur le site internet
qui s'affiche en bas de l'écran merci et
géraldine lisa grand plaisir
coach sportive est également co
organisatrice de ce bout de campagne est
clé pompiers de paris parlons cyclisme à
présent le troisième grand prix de
montigny le bretonneux s'est tenu ce
week-end dans les rues de la commune les
sportifs ont dû parcourir 78 km à une
moyenne de plus de 35 km heure michael
et demi d'euros et nicolas landry
dimanche 21 avril 10h près de 100
coureurs venus de toute la france se
sont déplacés pour participer à la
troisième édition du grand prix de
montigny le bretonneux dans les rues de
la commune
5 us course assez amusant et des virages
des montées descentes à droite à gauche
c'est amusant on a fait quelques tours à
l'échauffement et puis ils présentent
pas de grosses difficultés donc c'est
très très roulant ça va être très rapide
il faudra être fort pour réussir à
sortir et
une arrivée au sprint est assez probable
les coureurs de d1 et d2 se sont élancés
sur un circuit de 3 km fermée à la
circulation
les sportifs doivent réaliser 26 tours à
une moyenne de plus de 35 km heure et a
pas de stratégie est fixé parce que bon
on peut prévoir tout ce qu'on veut avant
ça se passe jamais comme on a prévu donc
quelque part ben il faut sentir la
course il faut après ça c'est de
l'expérience
il faut qu'ils apprennent ils font des
erreurs et c'est dans les erreurs québec
qui progressent après 78 km de course et
finalement romain barras qui remporté en
solitaire le grand prix pour avoir
distancé ses concurrents dans le dernier
tour ça fait toujours plaisir en y avait
du monde je sais qu'il y avait des bons
coureurs donc il fallait ça allait
partir avec le avec le bon groupe et à
et puis bah victoire fait toujours
plaisir c'est je sais qu'ils habitent du
niveau c'est assez relevé donc de finir
premier c'est toujours satisfaction
romain ba pourrait revenir l'année
prochaine pour remettre son titre en jeu
la compétition quand elle pourrait être
modifié elle devrait être déplacée au
mois de mars et pour refermer ce journal
beaucoup l'attendaient avec impatience
la sortie ce mercredi d'avengers endgame
dernier opus de la saga marvel alors
avec avez vous pensé de ce nouveau film
sur la bande de super héros marylène
iapichino et nicolas landry sont allé
récolter les premiers les premiers avis
ce midi à l'ugc ciné skywest sexting
havanaise première séance et le plus
classe on a eu les larmes qui montent
est quand même à de nombreuses reprises
et pas énormément d'action et je crois
que c'est tout ce qu'on attendait de ce
film on pouvait pas deviner ce qui
allait se passer
on avait beau prévoir et mettre des
théories aucune était vrai nom
traitement
c'est white house
en vrai marvel nous a vraiment j'ai
enfin ils nous ont jamais déçu nous est
déjà comme les autres enfin c'est
toujours assez magnifique
c'est ce type de film c'était très bien
les effets spéciaux les jeux de combat
non dans tout était tout était très bien
à certains moments du film vraiment très
triste
ascenseur émotionnel je dirais le dit le
décrire le film de l'année
mais voilà c'est la fin de ce set 8
journal demain jeudi vous retrouverez
wilfried richy à la présentation d'une
nouvelle édition à suivre le 7-8 débat
question ce soir mouvement des gilet
jaune est ce la fin des partis
politiques et des syndicats c'est la
question posée dans quelques minutes
belle soirée avec tv 78
[Musique]